[Music]
hello there watching the press preview a
first look then at what is on the front
pages as they come in time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor andrew pearce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
kevin mcguire happy new year
happy new year to you anna yep i don't
know when we stop probably february by
the time i see everybody but anyway
there we are um
front pages let's have a look just go
with your flow rights the metro as new
rules are to be introduced regarding
covert testing in the uk
the times focuses on the boost that the
new rules are likely to give to holidays
as britons can now avoid quarantine upon
arrival the delhi mirror draws attention
to the nhs facing a crisis as staff
absences and covet patient numbers rise
the telegraph leads with the acquittal
of four activists who pulled down the
statue of slave trader edward colston in
bristol last june
the daily express raises the question of
where will it all end in relation to
that same case
also makes the front of the guardian the
headline reads four cleared over
toppling of edward colston statue
and the financial times says investors
are ditching shares in technology firms
that did well during the pandemic in
favor of stocks such as banks and energy
producers whose fortunes are closely
linked to the economic recovery
well let's talk more with andrew pearson
kevin mcguire um and you've picked uh
the tennis row to start with kevin um in
a sense this is a really high profile
test of the status of a vaccinated or
non-vaccinated person
it is and whether if you're a famous uh
sports person the world's number one
male tennis player whether you get a
free pass which it seems that was
happening uh with djokovic until it was
an outcry in australia and uh scott
morrison the prior the pri uh prime
minister a right-wing government there
has had to act and create a diplomatic
uh
uh incident uh but djokovic himself he's
never said what he's um
status is which i think means he isn't
vaccinated
uh so why
should he be able to go to australia if
others can't uh look he stands a false
by himself but his wife has been
promoting the uh nutty 5g telephone mass
links to covert conspiracy theories so
uh he gets everything he he deserves if
he feels ugly humiliated well there we
are
that's that's the case and i do wonder
if in the
uk certainly with footballers whether it
should be uh you jab to play if fans
have to show uh
um certification being uh jabbed to
getting the grounds why not players
i mean it's where you stop isn't it i
mean this is an issue right across
europe we've seen austria with the
non-vaccinated effectively and lockdown
we've heard emmanuel macron uh you know
really dissing if that's the right word
the unvaccinated he's saying he's
deliberately trying to uh to irritate
them the new zealand prime minister
wanted them to be second-class citizens
i mean you know is this is this the
start i mean you know where does the uk
take this is it softly softly you know
get your booster it's a softer message
here but you know this is this is
interesting as we go forward isn't it
andrew
yeah and it's particularly in in
australia which has been very proud of
the fact it effectively locked its
borders down to visitors i mean unless
you're an australian almost impossible
to get in there
and this was the federal government uh
did some ridiculous deal where they gave
him some form of waiver when the outcry
started quite right rightly strip the
primaries of all of australia scott
morrison has intervened djokovic is a
petulant prima donna he's now trying to
get to now trying to get some form of
legal injunction to overturn the the the
ruling of the australian prime minister
this man has never quite understood why
in the world of tennis he's not as
popular as roger federer and rafa nadal
he looks in the mirror during this round
he might just get an idea because he's
an important role model in the world of
tennis he's one of the most famous
sportsmen on the planet one of the
richest one of the most successful and
he's gone on record as saying he does
not agree with the coveted vaccine now
he won't tell us whether he's had it or
not but as kevin says i think we can
work it out for ourselves and his wife
is promoting these barmy theories i
think they're quite right to throw him
out i hope we don't allow him to come
and play in wimbledon either and i think
we should make an example of these
people and kevin's right to talk about
footballers you know i checked the
figures still they're around 12 of
premier league players who've not been
jabbed that's a disgrace they're young
men they're important role models
they've got millions of followers on
instagram and if they spoke out and said
why they thought it was important it
would make such a big difference to the
war against kobe and we can see the
impacts on the nhs we can see the impact
on a number of these hospitals that have
had to declare major incidents and it's
because very largely according to the
local figures most of the people in
hospital are
unvaccinated
the government should say so every day
they should publish the the detailed
breakdown of the people who are on
intensive care in hospitals because of
kovid and who have not been vaccinated
would be a really important part of the
fight against this wretched uh pandemic
kevin you were itching i paused because
you were itching to come in but do you
mind if we move on i just was going to
say
that this is this is a controversial
issue and you have to be careful it
doesn't become yet another divisive
issue of which there are many including
the front page of the telegraph in the
guardian which is the colston four
walking free and many commentators uh
your own paper no in the in the mail too
uh has suggested this is unleashed you
know the right for political vandalism
kevin
yeah i think that's uh i think that's a
little rubbish though actually
and i i don't think it has unleashed uh
political vandalism look the
here the jury was there the 12 uh people
good and true heard the evidence they
accepted that the existence of a slavers
statue on a podium for people to look up
up to was a hate hate crime and they
found they didn't vandalize it but these
these verdicts are not absolutely
unusual and it isn't going to unleash
vandalism on a wide scale anyone's
thinking of getting along through
westminster square and trying to pull
down churchill's statue will soon find
the police levine and they'll be
punished uh in court as they have been
before attempts to deface or attacks on
the cenotaph have been punished before
but juries listen to the evidence and
they make decisions and all along i
remember clive ponting the civil servant
in the 1980s who leaked details of the
belgrano's movements before it was sang
in the falklands war he was acquitted
because a jury found it was in the
public interest what he did in the 1990s
women who damaged um a hawk uh warplane
and i think it was impressed him where
it was being built was going to be sold
to indonesia they said well we're trying
to present uh prevent uh genocide they
weren't found guilty of criminal damage
you've had extinction rebellion
protesters who smashed windows door
paint at the shell headquarters they
were acquitted by a jury because they
said the greater crime was the the
global uh environmental emergency and
what's happening to
to the world so we've got to see the
coastal verdict in that vein these
decisions are made by people we we back
jury trials juries will sit there they
will listen to the evidence and they
will make up their minds
yes sorry to interrupt you not
surprising i was going to say that the
four chose to be heard by a by a jury
but i mean you know people are arguing
that 15 years after this was put up
people were trying to get rid of it
that's more than 100 years and yet
others as you know andrew suggest can
you judge yesterday by the standards of
today can you effectively cleanse
history and all of those arguments that
goes with this statues movement
look there was there was a there was
there was a poll going on for three
years in bristol uh bristol live
reported this recently uh to see if
people wanted to get this statue down
and nothing happened about it bristol
has had a directly elected black mayor
uh in power for four or five years and
in that time he did nothing about
removing that statue it is not the place
of uh protesters to topple it
it chuck it in a canal and and for
of course it's the right of the court to
reject it but this is an act of
political vandalism it was an act of
criminal damage the right way to deal
with that was to do it through the
democratic process as i say i met repeat
the point it was a black elected mayor a
labour mayor in that city kier starmer
the labour leader also said this is not
the right way to remove statues it
should have been removed or and put in a
museum with a plaque explaining the
colonial past i think this is a really
sad day what's going to happen about
people who hated the fact oliver
cromwell uh uh
ensured that the king the king charles
first had his head chopped off are
people going to pull down his statues
because people say he was a despot and
wasn't a democrat this could this could
have a knock-on effect kevin's paper is
right this could unleash political
vandalism across the country and i think
it's a very sad day no it wasn't his
paper that said it but yes
no anna the the mayor of bristol wanted
that statue gone but there was no
community for him to be able to do it he
also wanted the name of the whole
coastal hall a big entertainment venue
change it has been changed since what
oliver
dowden did when he was culture secretary
he then was pushing forward powers in
which he will effectively decide which
statues stay off all because very
powerful people incredibly rich people
people who were slavers and exploiters
on a grand scale put or had put up
statues to themselves in an era when
three of us didn't have a vote and there
was no democracy doesn't mean they have
to be there forever in a day i think
it's the right of any community to
decide whether it wants these statues to
be there and i think putting slavers on
a pedestal is incredibly offensive to
many people but you need a process and a
process that could be done now the
process didn't exist
i just want to say again look that mayor
had years in which to get rid of that
statue through democratic procedures and
he didn't because he clearly didn't
think it was such a burning issue he had
plenty of opportunity kevin and he
flunked it you got lost he was trying he
was trying to do it
so lots more stuff come including all
things we've not yet talked about which
is the big changes in testing rules and
a prominent cabinet member tries to get
the chancellor to reverse course on
national insurer
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now andrew pearson kevin
mcguire welcome back to both of you to
the metro we go andrew just go with your
flow uh changes to testing rules to keep
everything moving just like the
isolational changes we've had already
well it it that it means but we're not
going to have to do so many tests pcr
tests uh
they're not they're one step now from
not going all the way down to a five-day
quarantine period but they're making it
easier to come out of quarantine uh
they're also making it easier for
foreign travel which is going to be
wonderful news for people who want to go
on a winter holiday in january it's
going to save families 300 pounds
i know the case numbers are soaring and
hospitalizations are rising but they are
still
half the amount of people in hospital in
january last year yeah and lots of
questions about this in premises
questions and the debate that followed
in the commons kevin uh you know from
labor um you know we might be riding
through this but the nhs isn't surfing
you know we heard from the smp leader in
the comments too being very critical of
the policy
you know is it devices is it supported
you know what happens next
yeah when schools are sending home uh
pupils and uh what 20 nhs trusts in
england alone have now declared uh you
know critical incidents because they've
got a lot of covered patients and also
got staff off off with kobe i'm
surprised the government's relaxing all
this at the moment and i think it's
probably because the testing system just
can't work was it 37 billion pounds
we've spent on it and we've got very
little uh in return
only say that but we've got free lateral
flow tests which much of the rest of the
world does not you know they really want
want them to be free but the but the p
the pcr tests are the gold standard
because you could have a negative uh
laplace low for armicron but you can
take a pcr and you'll discover you'll
have it and maybe some people don't want
that but that's the case
and of course the pcr detects variants
which the mutations which the lateral
flow doesn't but the two days after you
arrived back in the uk from uh from a
flight of train ferry whatever much of
that wasn't analyzed so people were in
one sense wasting their their time and
money and doing it and maybe
it's go for herd immunity now isn't it
johnson hasn't quite said that but he's
letting omicron uh rip because it
doesn't seem as severe as the other
forms because it's not in your lungs
it's in your it's in your your throat
and the death rate isn't going up
mercifully but it's still a big big
gamble yeah i'm sure that will be uh
denied again uh by the government and uh
certainly for lateral flow
they say that it does uh you know it
does test positive when you're at your
most infectious so that's the
reassurance on that i've got time i'm
just gonna very quickly read the story
we were gonna do which is uh jacob
rees-mogg has called for the national
insurance increase to be abandoned uh at
the cabinet meeting as the country
struggles with the cost of living crisis
caused by the pandemic we'll do that uh
next time
andrew kevin lovely to see you
thank you very much